Russia's invasion of Ukraine is not only
radically changing Europe's geopolitics,
security and worldview, it is also bringing
huge changes for Russia... And as time goes
on this will become more and more noticeable.
In a recent video here on VisualPolitik we told
you how the sanctions on Russia are achieving
many of the goals they set out to achieve.
In fact, Russia is, in quantitative terms,
the most sanctioned country in the world.
Specifically, 2023 started with 13,600 sanctions
and restrictions of all kinds on the Russian
State, the country's companies as well as many
oligarchs close to the Kremlin. Of these, almost
11,000 were imposed after the invasion
of Ukraine on 24 February 2022.
For the sake of comparison, Iran, the second most
sanctioned country in the world, has just over
4,000 sanctions and restrictions, while Syria and
North Korea have 2,600 and 2,100 respectively.
And that is not all. Western economies
and in general most of Ukraine's allies
have made gigantic efforts to progressively
get rid of everything coming from Russia:
its gas, its oil, the money of
the oligarchs... Everything,
except, one thing: supplies from
the Russian nuclear sector.
We are talking specifically about Rosatom,
a huge industrial group owned by the
Russian government that, for now, has escaped
sanctions. It has been spared for one reason:
Right now, what this company offers is much
more difficult to replace than hydrocarbons.
So despite the enormous efforts
Zelenskiy has made morning,
noon and night to pressure his allies to sanction
Rosatom as well, so far he has failed to do so.
N1(9 January 2023: Ukraine expects EU to include
Russia's Rosatom in next sanctions – Reuters)
And keep in mind, we are talking about none
other than Russia's state-owned atomic
energy company. And that's not all.
This nuclear giant is virtually the only Russian
company that we can say is truly on a par with the
best in the world in its sector, whether in terms
of technology, competitiveness, costs or quality.
It is something like the great exception
of the Russian industrial fabric,
a productive environment that is, to put it
bluntly, characterized by its inefficiency,
its excessive corruption and a deep technological
gap with respect to its western counterparts.
But you can see that this is not the case
with this company, quite the contrary.
[Of course, the fact that the Western nuclear
industry has been battered by the anti-nuclear
policies over recent decades has logically
contributed to Rosatom's gain in market share].
Now then... What is Rosatom really, what do
they do specifically, why haven't sanctions
been imposed on this company, and could this
change? In other words, are there grounds for
sanctioning the Russian nuclear giant? What role
does this company play in the political, economic
and military fabric of Vladimir Putin's Russia?
Well, in this video we are going to answer all
these questions and a few more.
Let's get started.
T1(PUTIN'S GOLDEN CHILD)
As most of you probably already know,
the fall of the Soviet Union was
followed by a period of several
years of deep crisis where a huge economic
and industrial collapse was experienced.
And obviously the nuclear sector was no
exception... Despite the fact that the Soviet
Union was a huge power in civil nuclear energy.
For example, it was in the USSR that the world's
first nuclear power plant to feed electricity
into the grid was born. It did this in 1954.
The Obninsk plant, with just 5 MW
of power, made history, but that
was only the beginning of a long road ahead.
Since then, the Soviets have designed or built
more than 60 nuclear reactors distributed
throughout the country and the rest of the
communist bloc made up of countless satellite
countries. In this way, they gained significant
know-how and a good reputation, at least
until the Chernobyl nuclear accident in 1986.
[Then, not surprisingly, everything changed].
But the fact is that when the USSR collapsed,
the entire industrial fabric of the State also
collapsed. Some of these traditional industries
never recovered, others did, but at a much
lower standard than their western competition,
and others, on the other hand, were
reestablished with care by the government.
The latter case was precisely
what happened with Rosatom.
Vladimir Putin himself made it a personal priority
to revive the nuclear industry. To this end,
in 2006 he enacted a law that sought
to create an entire long-term strategic
framework for the nuclear sector, and
shortly thereafter, in 2007, Putin
himself founded Rosatom as a State corporation.
Behind this decision was the Russian government's
concern about the widening gap between
electricity supply and demand. In other
words, with Rosatom they intended to solve the
electricity shortage once and for all and thus
prevent it from continuing to harm the economy.
In addition, during the 1990s, Russia was left
out of the international nuclear energy market
because it did not have a reference producer. To
give you an idea, between the early 1990s and
the mid-2000s, more than 100 nuclear reactors
were built around the globe. Russia was not able
to participate in the construction and design of
any of them. In other words, Moscow understood
that it was missing out on big business.
So as we say around here,
no sooner said than done.
Rosatom was launched with an amazing financial
boost from the Russian State and with Vladimir
Putin one hundred percent involved in
this mission. In fact, it is he himself
who decides who runs this company and who
also makes the most important appointments.
The fact is that with this company, Russian
nuclear energy has once again made headway and
today it is already one of the major international
players in the nuclear energy sector.
But, to be clearer, it is enough for me to
give you just one fact: of the 53 nuclear
reactors that were under construction worldwide in
mid-2022, 20 were being built by Rosatom, and of
these, 17 were outside Russia. In other words, we
are talking about a market share of almost 40%.
France and South Korea are also building reactors
outside their respective borders, but they are
only involved in a couple of projects each.
But it doesn't end there. In many cases,
the Russian company is also responsible for the
maintenance and supervision of Russian-technology
nuclear reactors around the world. We are talking
about approximately 20 percent of the almost
450 reactors in operation.
In other words, we can safely
say that Rosatom, in its little more than 15
years of operations, has managed to dominate
the international nuclear market. Or at
least become the most important player.
C1("The Russians are hypercompetitive, no one
in the Organization for Economic Cooperation
and Development [OECD] can compete with what they
offer". – Marc-Antoine Eyl-Mazzega, director of
the energy and climate center at the Institut
Français des Relations Internationales)
Surprised? Well, wait, there's still
more, much more. We've only just begun.
If you think about it for a moment, the reason
why the West has not sanctioned Rosatom cannot
only be its nuclear reactor exports.
After all, the United States has no Russian
nuclear reactors, and in Europe, nuclear
energy has been marginalized for years,
and now that it is making a comeback,
most of the nuclear technology suppliers
are Western or South Korean. Not Russian.
So why on earth is Rosatom not being sanctioned
at once? What else is in play for this possibility
to be completely ruled out for the time being?
Well, here comes perhaps the most interesting
part of this whole story. Pay close attention.
But first, remember that if you like the economy
and the best of VisualPolitik style you can't miss
our sister channel VisualEconomik. For example,
have you ever wondered what will happen when
oil runs out - which according to predictions
will be in about 50 years? We leave a link in
the description for you to check it out.
T2(ATOMS MADE IN RUSSIA)
Financial sanctions, restrictions on
technology purchases, sanctions on Russian
gas and oil were imposed relatively quickly.
However, at the time of making this video,
Rosatom had managed to fend off
any punishment or restrictions.
And this obviously must have an explanation.
And it does: this company not only designs
and builds nuclear reactors,
but also enriches uranium.
And although we can find major Western
suppliers here, Rosatom is the world's
largest producer of enriched uranium,
with about 30 percent of production
and almost half of the world's capacity.
In addition, it controls 17 percent of the
global nuclear reactor fuel market.
And according to the company itself,
73 nuclear reactors in 13 different countries run
on its fuel. And we are not just talking about
the former Soviet nuclear power plants.
In 2021, for example, Rosatom provided
nearly a quarter of all nuclear fuel
used by US nuclear power plants.
What’s more, it is estimated that even
in a scenario of supplier switching,
the Russians will retain at least 15 percent
of the pie in the United States in the short
to medium term. This is because it is a very
slow and costly process to specialize in nuclear
fuel production at a reasonable scale and price.
Clearly its market share in Europe is not minor.
The Russians provide around 20 percent of
all uranium imported into the European Union,
behind only Niger and Kazakhstan, as
well as 26 percent of enriched uranium.
In fact, from time to time, Russian cargo
planes can still be seen in European skies
flying to countries like Hungary or Slovakia
with nuclear fuel, thanks precisely to the
exceptions that were introduced to the ban on
the entry of Russian aircraft. If they carry
nuclear fuel they can fly freely.
But why is all this so important,
and is it really so essential to keep
Rosatom free from Western sanctions?
Well... the truth is yes, and it
may not be exactly what you're
thinking. Let's take a look at it.
T3(STRATEGIC INFLUENCE)
Rosatom is a huge company with a large
portfolio of contracts in the nuclear sector.
To give you an idea, in 2021 it reported
record profits of $20 billion. So we are
not exactly talking about a small company.
And not only that, in that same year the holding
company, Atomenergoprom, in which a large part
of Rosatom's activity is unified, had a portfolio
of foreign orders of close to $140 billion
dollars to be executed over the next decade.
And yes, some of the nuclear reactor construction
contracts that swell that huge number of projects
are in NATO countries, some of them are even
supposed allies of Ukraine. Check it out.
N2(27 August 2022: Hungary moves ahead with
construction of Russian-built nuclear reactors
Despite Moscow's war in Ukraine, works at the
Paks plant will kick off in 'coming weeks,'
Hungary's foreign minister said – Politico)
N3(30 July 2022: Russia's Rosatom signs new
construction contract for Turkish nuclear plant
The Turkish government aims to start operating
the first reactor at the total 4,800-megawatt
(MW) plant before a general election next year.
President Tayyip Erdogan has previously suggested
that Turkey could work with Russia on the
construction of two further plants. – Reuters)
So, reactor construction and maintenance is by
far the most lucrative business for Rosatom.
In fact, let us give you another fact. The
annual imports of uranium and nuclear fuel
from Russia by the United States and the
European Union are essential but amount
to barely $1 billion dollars a year.
Yes, it is a lot of money, but it is nothing
compared to the nearly $200 billion that were
imported from Russia in hydrocarbons
just before the war. And neither does
it come close to what Rosatom earns from
its reactor and power plant business.
So, with all this, you may be wondering...
so couldn't Rosatom be sanctioned to prevent
it from being able to build new reactors
and power plants, while continuing to buy
uranium and nuclear fuel from them until
those supplies can be fully replaced?
Well, yes, it could, and that would probably
hurt them the most. But there are two drawbacks.
On the one hand, taking this step in a market
as restricted and with few suppliers like this
one might make Russia itself willing
to sacrifice those revenues in order
to leave the West without its nuclear fuel.
And this, in the United States and Europe,
could cause real supply problems for power
plants at a time of high hydrocarbon prices.
And then there is another problem, and that is
that there are not so many suppliers of nuclear
technology for modern power plants.
In other words, banning imports of
these technologies would probably
generate a bottleneck of orders to
the civil nuclear industry in countries such
as the United States, France and South Korea
that would threaten the world's energy supply.
And it would do so precisely in what is expected
to be the greatest period of electrification in
the history of mankind due to the fulfillment of
climate objectives, something that, by the way, we
have already talked about here on VisualPolitik.
So the reality is that, like it or not, the
United States and the European Union will have
to be very cautious about imposing sanctions
against Rosatom, and that is precisely why
Rosatom has so far escaped unscathed.
Now, is this irreversible? Well, no,
of course not. In fact, both the United States
and the European Union already have plans to
boost their production of enriched
uranium and fuel for power plants.
N4(US Redoubles Efforts to End
Dependence on Russian Nuclear Fuel
The White House is prioritizing development
of domestic uranium-enrichment capacity and
predicted key lawmakers will fall in
line, so that a fuel-manufacturing
plan can be in train by 2025 – Bloomberg)
N5(Nuclear included in EU's repowering plan
The European Commission has formally adopted the
REPowerEU plan which aims to rapidly reduce EU
dependence on Russian fossil fuels. The plan [...]
highlights the importance of coordinated action to
reduce dependence on Russian nuclear materials
and fuel cycle services. – World Nuclear News)
But of course, until all that
materializes, Rosatom will remain
of crucial importance for its supply.
The risk now is that dependence on the
West will allow this company to become a sort of
by-pass for sanctions and divert technologies,
supply purchases and profits to
finance the military campaign.
For the time being, Rosatom has already
actively participated in the invasion of
Ukraine, as it is the current operator of the
Zaporizhzhia nuclear power plant and also its
de facto owner as long as it remains occupied.
In addition, the company is acting on the orders
of the Russian government in operating this
Ukrainian power plant, which is the largest
in Europe with a total of six reactors.
Since the beginning of the occupation of
the power plant, units have been being switched
on and off at the whim of the Kremlin to undermine
the morale of the Ukrainians and prevent
them from earning money through the export
of electricity to their European neighbors.
In fact, this is one of the main arguments used
by the Ukrainian government to demand that this
company be sanctioned as soon as possible, but, as
you have seen, even in spite of its collaboration
in the war, things are not so straightforward.
In short, Rosatom, rather than being a huge
financial lifeline for the Kremlin – which it also
is – functions as a strategic political pressure
trump card. It is a red line where, unfortunately,
in this case, Russia does have the upper hand.
But now, at this point, it's your turn.
Do you think the United States and Europe would
do well to put their nuclear energy production
at risk in order to sanction Rosatom?
Could this company be Putin's last great
strategic asset outside the battlefield?
Well, leave us your opinions here below,
in the comments. And remember, if you liked this
video, don't forget to like and subscribe to our
channel so you don't miss any news.
And remember, you can help us grow
and improve by joining our community on
Patreon. We’ll leave you the link below.
Once again, thank you very much for
watching. Take care and see you next time